collection givenchy
[Musique]
chaque saison la collection de haute
couture la plus réussie reçoit le prix
du dé d'or décerné par un jury de
journalistes
cette fois ci c'est la collection
givenchy qui reçoit le dé d'or et c'est
aussi un cadeau d'anniversaire puisque
la maison de couture fête ses 30 ans les
blues ont remplacé les vestes cette
saison plus ou moins cool plus ou moins
ample ici très long jacqueline betinho
j'habite une elena
j'ai 38 ans
trois enfants
qui aime que moi spécialement l'une de
mes filles avec passion tout ce qui est
tout ce qui est vous tous qui est le
rêve finalement ça représente un petit
peu un rêve mais pourquoi la haute
couture plutôt que le prêt-à-porter
parce que c'est c'est vraiment ce dont
tu aurais je pense depuis depuis
toujours le prêt-à-porter pareil comme
son nom l'indiqué plus à la portée de
tout le monde moi même en tout cas est
vraiment la couture présenter quelque
chose de féerique goût du jeu vous
pourrez ressentir enfin car je suis
dingue
[Musique]
les fans des environs le sag et
enverront leurs clubs respectifs
à main levée
avocat un jeu seule la chanson française
environ ton père lachaise pour une
sortie au vin
qu'est ce qui vous a frappé là la
perfection la perfection dans
dans les tissus sont très jolis la
perfection dans les détails j'ai
remarqué qu'on ne voit aucune fermeture
aucune agrafes
notamment dans tout ce qui est drapé qui
est ingénieusement fermé de coaching et
la perfection dans les modèles sont en
faire on a l'impression d'assister à des
apparitions successives
c'est vraiment
magnifique en appréciant chaque modèle
chaque mannequin du moins aride avec son
rythme en approcher sur le corps comme
s'il ne s'était rien produit avant
jusqu'à l'ultime minute
le shanghai il ya encore sur une coque
de noix s'y tenait à karak place les
jours qui passent sans toit et non de
forme on prolonge nuit à bord le bourdon
je reprends ce retour dans quelques
jours c'est long c'est pour toi ma jolie
que je suis sorti vainqueur de ses six
le père du où l'on tué ou l'on aime gst
part de simandou père mort ma conscience
pour sortir victorieux du câble et
d'espérance
tu avais promis en quittant je craignais
d'être un petit peu dépaysé du rapport à
ce que j'ai l'habitude de voir et
franchement imagine très bien tous ces
modèles dans la rue mon réveil je
t'avais pro millions de teu quittant des
pièces d'or pourtant bracelet je crois
que c'est raté
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour le soir robe fourreau droite devant
mais qu'ils ont dans le dos comme
l'indication d'une tournure
ces lignes fin du 19e siècle et
contemporaine les peintres
impressionnistes reviennent qu'à la mode
et vont faire l'objet d'une grande
exposition à paris ce printemps
je te veut confiante je te sens captive
je te veux d'autres
je sens qu'un tir je t'en prie de ne
soit pas ma motion
[Musique]
vient l'eau
je
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le c3 au gré du courant pop tu es dans
le lit du torrent et dans le mien c'est
une bien quittons la rive
[Musique]